the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
to the 2022 U.S and U.S women's Chess
Championship
please welcome executive director of the
St Louis chess club Tony Rich
welcome to
thank you all so much and thank you for
joining us in the uh 2022 U.S chess and
U.S women's Chess Championship closing
ceremony
what a couple of events uh first of all
I'd like to start off by thanking all of
the players in a big round of applause
for their fighting spirit and
determination across all these rounds
[Applause]
this was the longest U.S championship in
U.S Women's Championship that we have
held at the club for those of you who
have played chess before the Internet
you may remember there were days where
chess tournaments did go on for many
many days and in fact almost a month at
a time and that's exactly what these
championships were from October 4th
through the 20th we had the very best
American chess players men and women
competing across both fields from almost
five hundred thousand dollars in prize
money it was really exciting to watch
[Applause]
the U.S championships are important to
the St Louis chess community and to the
St Louis Community in general because
they Spotlight these top American
players as so as a chess fan I look at
all of you and I think about the fact
that I watched Irena play the 2009 U.S
Championship I Remember You Walking In
in this leather jacket and you looked
really tough I remember watching gotta
kamski play a playoff against Alejandro
Ramirez and Alejandro was fighting so
hard but just couldn't quite come
through these events really are an
opportunity for us to bring our American
chess Community together to bring the
the chess family of the United States
together here in St Louis which is our
home for chess so welcome home everyone
I'd like to thank a few folks before I
hand the microphone over of course none
of this will be possible without the
benefactors the founders The Visionaries
for the St Louis chess club Dr Jeannie
Karen singfield and rexingfield thank
you both
[Applause]
I'd also like to thank Shannon Bailey
and all the folks at the World Chess
Hall of Fame we've hosted a few events
there if you missed the John Donaldson
lecture on the Fisher spasky match you
really miss something special make sure
you go to the World Chess Hall of Fame
YouTube page the the video was live
streamed you can watch it now on demand
uh really really a great watch and
definitely worth watching so in addition
to Shannon and all the folks at the hall
of fame I'd also like to thank all of
our broadcast folks Randy sinkfield and
his crew at Spectrum Studios Uh Kevin
Depew in his crew at Silverback our
marketing folks Courtney setoff Rebecca
Buffington
Brian Flowers our journalist for this
event was Vanessa West you know it's
funny we say it takes a village to
produce something like this but it
really is the combined efforts of some
very very talented people in their
specific skill set so we've got the
grand masters of Chess we also have the
grand masters of Journalism of social
media of
play-by-play commentary of interviews a
big round of applause for all the folks
that made the event happen
[Applause]
and now with all that said it is my
pleasure to introduce to you
um the the woman of the hour you have
seen her ring the opening ceremony Bell
at almost every event that we felt at
the St Louis chess club she's the
co-founder of the St Louis chess club Dr
Jeannie Karen singfield
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
welcome to St Louis
I was thinking about Chess and how it's
affected the life of myself and my
children and my husband
I became an inventor because I built a
chest to go
backpacking set and now I'm a
professional inventor with patents you
know I wrote that crummy little learn to
read and write chess and now I'm a
bestseller today on the on Amazon see
life is see what chess does for you and
then we just did that Bicentennial chess
board so what chess does is it opens
your mind
not just the best players and how great
you are playing but the impact it has
for all of us
including Rex he finally gets to do
something that I used to limited him to
do right
but then I used to say true that you
know how expensive could it be
so I would like to introduce the
Godfather of American Jess Rex sinkfield
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you Genie
what an incredible
and extraordinary championships
congratulations to all of the players
you were all wonderful fighting Spirits
you made everything exciting
based on the top three winners in both
Fields four of the six winners live in
St Louis
which I'm proud to say
[Applause]
and all of the rest of you are invited
to move here
you know
the U.S Championship field had seven
players rated over 2700.
and the U.S Women's Championship field
was one of the most exciting ever put
together
and congratulations to our winners both
Fabiano and Jennifer
I want to thank the best commentary team
in the world I'm not tired of saying it
for their amazing and entertaining daily
broadcast join me please in thanking
Grand Masters Christian charola yasser01
and Anastasia corlevich
[Applause]
and joy Bray who oversees almost
everything in the universe here
[Applause]
I think she actually runs the solar
system
um
but thank you Joy for all of your
amazing work here and to Randy and his
team at Spectrum Studios along with
Silverback Studios Leonard our dgt
specialist and photographer along with
Fuller photography you all put on the
best production broadcast ever
although we are under construction you
all managed to keep the show going at
the level of Excellence that we are used
to and we just expect
thank you thank you very much we
couldn't do all of this without the
amazing staff
and Tony you and your team did an
outstanding job this is the 13th
Championship we have hosted and they
just continue to get better
in fact I think we had to do one every
year
so
the uh that's right the walls the World
Chess Hall of Fame led by curators
Shannon and Emily your team does an
amazing job exhibiting the artistic side
of this wonderful game and I would also
like to acknowledge Courtney sudhoff
Rebecca Buffington Brian Flowers and our
PR marketing and Communications team at
the club and World Chess Hall of Fame
they all truly do a great job
now for some
for some statistics on the game boring
yet exciting we had 204 countries view
these championships including Turk
manistan Western Sahara and Ukraine
the highest age group of viewing was 25
to 34 and I it feels great to be part of
that group
oh yeah you really get that one don't
you
so on YouTube we had nearly 822
000 compared to 340 000 viewers last
year and over 3.3 million viewers
compared to 1.2 million viewers in 2022
on YouTube and approximately 41 million
viewer minutes compared to 20 million
viewer minutes last year on YouTube
lastly I'd like to say I'm already
looking forward to next year hosting the
tournament in I'm really looking forward
to our new space thank you all very much
[Applause]
yes
some of you know that I'm also a chess
arbiter
in addition to being the the executive
director of the St Louis chess club so
I'd like to thank my orbiting team first
of all
um they did an amazing job as they
always do the chief Arbiter for the U.S
Championship was Frank Guadalupe the
chief Arbiter for the U.S Women's
Championship was Chris Byrd and the
deputy Arbiter for both events was
Enrique Huerta thank you guys
[Applause]
you know Randy Bauer came to St Louis uh
in I guess it must have been 2009 late
2008 early 2009
um and he's told this story before
probably right here on the same
microphone at the same Podium about how
the U.S championships came to St Louis
and
um
I guess what I can say is that I was a
very new uh chess organizer we had just
opened the chess club at the time and
the thought of being able to host a U.S
Championship here in St Louis was not
even on the radar it really wasn't even
something that we had considered but
Randy and Rex met and that fateful
evening led to where we are here today
14 years later so without further Ado
the President of the U.S Chess
Federation Randy Bauer
[Applause]
so I'm not going to tell that story
again because I've told him many times
but I have observed a lot of U.S
championships I've been a member of the
United States Chess Federation for over
50 years and I remember the days when it
was a nice tournament it was held in a
little hotel somewhere in a back room
there was no media attention there
wasn't Facebook or any of what exists
right now and what we have right now is
in my opinion I think it's shared by
many around the world the best
championship of any country in the
United States and it is because of Rex
and Dr Jeannie Karen singfield and the
St Louis chess club
so what we um you know we're here to
celebrate now are of course is results
of that and and I'm really pleased to be
a part of that and have seen all of the
Fighting Chess that has gone on
um over the last couple of weeks what I
am also pleased to say is that yes
indeed next year uh we will return the
U.S chess championships both the
um the championship and the Women's
Championship to St Louis and we can't be
more excited about that
[Applause]
and as was suggested that you make St
Lucie address home we have made St Louis
arches home U.S chess is now located in
St Louis I expect we're going to be here
and I'm hopeful that we and the
tournament will be permanent residents
of the city of St Louis
[Applause]
so I thank you all for what you bring to
chess in the United States you know the
activity is growing our membership is
growing we're getting back to the
numbers we were pre-covered there's
great interest in the activity and you
all are primarily responsible for that
so I thank you again Dr
um Jeannie Karen singfield and Rex and
the St Louis chess club for your
assistance in that
[Applause]
I want to know the joke of under come on
what's so funny
okay so the part of the program that
we've all come here for
the presentation of awards
um we'll start with the U.S Women's
Championship so if Jeannie and Rex if
you join me on the stage here
thank you uh beginning with third place
in the U.S Women's Championship one of
those St Louis residents that Rex
happened to mention women's Grandmaster
Talia Cervantes please come to the stage
[Applause]
sure and if you guys if you could step
this way Rex Genie Talia if you could
come this way into the light a little
bit for me the photographers have
requested
listen to The Dutch guy
good
good thank you very much
[Applause]
in second place after an amazing uh
tournament really the whole thing but
especially after uh an exciting playoff
today we really enjoyed watching from
New York Grand Master Irina Crush
[Applause]
and step this way guys a little bit
smile for the cameras
right
[Applause]
and finally your 2022 U.S women's
champion from Virginia
her second time winning the U.S Women's
Championship we have women's Grandmaster
Jennifer Yu
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
if you'd like to give a few remarks
or or not that's okay too you can just
say no
hi everyone
um
so I really thought about writing a
speech but I just didn't have any words
to kind of describe this time at all I
just don't know how to put it into words
but
um first I like to of course thank the
St Louis chess club for organizing this
event
um so many people put so much effort
into this and I think you know of course
Rex and Genie for making this possible
the staff the tournament directors
photographers commentators thank you
everyone for making this such an amazing
experience
um I also definitely want to shout out
all of my competitors because this
tournament was just crazy like I don't I
don't know how to describe it
um every round was definitely
interesting and I don't think anyone had
an idea of how this is going to end up
um so especially shout out to my
co-champion Irina for being such a great
competitor this was just a wild ride all
together
um I'd also like to thank my family for
being my rock and supporting me for you
know pursuing my passion and
um I want to mention like the last time
I was standing here I was a junior in
high school and now I would have been a
junior in college but um took a gap year
but the thing is I know I wouldn't be
here today if it wasn't for like all the
wonderful people I've interacted with
over the last few years if you have
amazing friends who just supported me
throughout everything like I genuinely
feel so lucky and fortunate
um for all of you guys and just thank
you
[Applause]
congratulations again Jennifer
the trophies are designed and
commissioned by U.S chess and we will
engrave both the travel version that she
gets to take with her as well as the
permanent version that will stay here at
the World Chess Hall of Fame with the
Winner's names as well okay moving on to
the U.S Championship section uh in third
place we talked about those St Louis
residents we have yet another one here
uh Grand Master Lanier Dominguez
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
all right congratulations linear
in second place boy I keep saying this
another St Louis resident Grand Master
Ray Robson
[Applause]
[Music]
congratulations Ray thank you so much
[Applause]
and finally it's my pleasure to
introduce to you the 2022 U.S chess
champion from St Louis
Grand Master Fabiano caruana
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
Fabiano if you'd like to give us a few
words please
[Music]
good evening everyone
I'll try to keep this brief since I'm
sure everyone wants to celebrate the
evening
um I really want to extend my thanks to
everyone who makes chess and St Louis
possible and who made makes chess in the
United States
uh such an amazing thing and I'm really
humbled because I've I've been playing
chess here for six years and I've seen a
lot of my colleagues a lot of the
players who I grew up admiring
a lot of the players were my age and now
a lot of the younger players and seeing
them grow up and get stronger and make
chess in this country stronger and
stronger is really really an honor and a
privilege
and I'd love to thank Dr Jeannie and Rex
sinkfield
for their invaluable contribution to
chess
for all the support
that makes tournaments like this and so
many more throughout the years possible
also everyone at the chess club
Joy Bray Tony Rich everyone else and at
the World Chess Hall of Fame
um
and on a personal note I'd like to thank
all my friends here uh all the people
who supported me and who
um kept me in High Spirits during the
event
especially my longtime friend and the
person who helped me in the event
Alejandro Ramirez
[Applause]
and everyone else who loves chess and
who loves watching it thank you
and before he goes the presentation of
the championship jacket if you guys
Jeannie Rex if you would the jacket
right there I'll take this one
nope you can leave the trophies we got
to engrave it anyway
it's like that whole golf thing right
the Green Jacket
[Applause]
thank you Rex and Genie also that's okay
Genie we got to get it engraved for him
he can't take it yet
yep you guys are all set thank you very
much
[Applause]
and in fact we are almost all set
penultimately it is my pleasure to
introduce to you uh the zonal president
for U.S chess so let me speak for just a
moment uh the U.S trust Federation is
the governing body for chess in America
they Grant the St Louis chess club the
privilege to host the U.S championship
in the U.S Women's Championship now
every other year those events are uh
called zonal tournaments which means
they qualify for the World Championship
cycle so Alan and Alan priest who I'm
now introducing in his role as the zonal
president for U.S chess it's his job to
be the official who oversees U.S chess
and international chess relations so
um Alan will be presenting to fide soon
who the players from the US and women's
championships are who have qualified to
play in the world championship cycle so
without further Ado Alan priest
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
it's an honor to join you here tonight
I wasn't sure I was going to make it on
time I I had to come in from Louisville
Kentucky
and it's normally a four hour and 15
minute trip that with construction and
traffic took me five hours and a half
which got me here just in time
and I was not at the opening ceremony
because I was coming back from Costa
Rica for a continental meeting as we
were trying to sort out things like the
Continental championships those are part
of my role
uh the United States is a single nation
Zone we're Zone 2.1 in fide
and as Tony mentioned uh this event
serves as the zonal championship every
other year many of you all are aware
because of the change in the tournament
timing we have changed the time the year
in which the zonal falls in the old
schedule with the event being in April
that was the zonal championship was in
the same year as the world championship
cycle with moving the event to October
then this will be the quote this is the
qualifying event for the World Cup cycle
for 2023.
so without further Ado The Zone 2.1 has
two slots
for the Women's World Cup
I'm sorry the Women's World Championship
cycle and the top two finishers in this
event qualify so that would of course be
the champion Jennifer you and
Grandmaster Arena Crush
[Applause]
now it is possible that we will get more
slots than that it is also possible that
one of our automatic our qualifiers may
qualify in some other way in which case
we will simply move down the list and so
any player who has finished with a
positive score
in this event would be able possibly to
fill one of the slots from our zone so
that goes all the way down to uh to
Megan Lee so any one of the players who
finished for Megan on up has a shot at
being in that category
in the
open section
we have five slots for the cycle again
the same thing applies we may have some
of the people who are in those upper
slots will qualify in other ways in
which case we will simply offer the
invitation to the next person in line
all the way down to the to the last
person who scored in a positive score so
the top five from this event were
Fabiano caruana
Ray Robson Lanier Dominguez Wonder Liang
and Wesley so but you may make travel
plans because a couple of those people
will qualify in other ways for certain
so next we would go to Sam Shanklin Hans
Neiman Jeffrey Zhang and Sam Sevin so we
might see any or all of those folks in
the next World Championship cycle thank
you so much
and thank you Alan and thank all of you
again for helping us make the 2022 U.S
championship and U.S Women's
Championship so successful don't forget
you can tune in to uschesschamps.com
November 1st through the 11th to watch
the fall chess classic and uh check back
with us soon early next year for the
Cairns cup which will be in the first
couple of months so thank you all enjoy
the party and and have a good night
thanks
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited
foreign